bill can you go get
oliver and
cordelia in here
well good morning everybody afternoon um
it's crazy time
um
purpose of today's meeting is for us to
get ourselves organized in terms of how
we're going to go with our interim study
bills
also i'd like to take a moment talk
about some of the
requests the senate messages which we've
had come in from the senate
this committee's been loaded with them
we had 15 bills come in
um that were to respond to and you've
gotten emails from me
where we are we have uh we're concurring
with 11 of them
and then there's four of which we are
not going to concur with that are going
to go to a committee a conference
uh the reasons why we have committee at
conferences going on is that the
the
party on the other side of the wall is
once again
you know making christmas trees out of
our our bills
and
even though many of the folks over there
have said we we didn't want to do it
some have so we have omnibus type bills
that are coming out of 1661 specifically
is one of those bills it was our career
technical education bill as you recall
where we're talking about the
competencies we're talking about the
calendar alignment between
all the districts within a regional
area
that bill has been added with bail
reform with health and human services
with workforce housing with
extraordinary needs grant etc
and so there's a lot added on to that
and
it
presents a lot of confusion as to how
and where how we're going to
work here
so on on that side and that is the the
bill that is primarily of concern to us
that's been added with the most most
legislation
today though what we want to do is
get ourselves organized in terms of
where we're going with the interim
studies and i've had a lot of
communication from folks here in the
committee as far as which bills you'd
like to serve on and what i'd like to do
today
sort of walk through that get ourselves
organized find out who would like to be
on bills there may be some bills that
we're saying it we can just take care of
it with one session perhaps towards late
latter part of the fall
as you know that we can work on these
bills through the month of june
we cannot do so in july and august
that's sacred time where nobody comes
into here unless it's some other type of
statutory committee which is meeting for
some other purpose
uh so we'd have to pick it back up in in
september october and get things
concluded there as reports have to be
back out
and and uh action taken by us the action
is either it's either up or it's down or
it's up with some recommendations and
that's what we have the ability to do
and there are a number of issues which
we addressed
this year which i feel that there's a
lot of opportunity for us to make some
solid recommendations now and have
legislation come forward in the next
biennium
yes i don't know if we have any students
with us or girl scouts
no do we
oh there's some hands up there could you
explain some of the terms
of conference and all that
okay it's an educational there's a whole
process and will at which a bill becomes
a law
and any legislator sitting on the table
here
in the november when you first get
elected can put forth legislation
and that legislation's worked with
people over in what we call the office
of legislative services where there's
attorneys over there help us craft this
legislation in legalese so it's crafted
in a way that it doesn't conflict
hopefully with other areas of statute
already in print
once that gets done the the bill which
was or the legislation put forth let's
say by representative nelson here
would come forth as a legislative
service request lsr
that lsr then other legislators look at
it and decide i'm going to sign on to
that or not sign on it and be a
co-sponsor when that's all said and done
it's proposed and sent to the house to
the speaker of the house that's the
person who's elected to maintain order
within our house and represent all of us
then the bill is taken and put forth to
a particular committee we have a number
of statutory committees you're in one
today which is education there's health
and your services there's agriculture
there's
uh natural resources on the other side
in the senate uh how many committees do
we have about 20
23 or so committees
and it can go anywhere from uh
health and human services to criminal
justice to judiciary affairs so once
it's assigned in the committee then the
committee then has to hear that bill
so it's brought forth by the sponsor of
the bill it's heard and the bill then is
in the uh ownership of the committee the
committee then has to have hearing on
that bill and then we after we've had an
opportunity to have the public give
input whether they're for or against or
in between somewhere
or with recommendations how maybe to
improve it it's we exec the bill that
means we take action on the bill we can
either approve the bill
or we can not approve the bill give it
an itl or we can retain the bill in the
first year of the biennium
in this case
we're in the second year we have
retained
15 i believe it's 15 bills for interim
study that means where they weren't
quite ready but they may be ready after
we work on it more once the bill is
approved by the committee it's sent back
to the house floor for action by the
whole body all 400 representatives take
action on it following that the bill may
go to a second committee if there's a
financial note attached to it or if
their way we're looking for where we're
going to get the funding to support that
bill we'd send it to ways and means
comes back to the house floor again it
takes action and it's on its way to the
senate and it repeats that whole cycle
in the senate
they have their hearings they exec the
bill
when they modify it
then the bill is then sent back to the
house and we look at what they modified
amended and if we concur
with that modification we're basically
saying we concur it's ready now to go on
to the governor's desk
if we non-concur
and request a committee conference and
that's where we are right now we're
receiving a lot of those house bills
back
and we had in this committee alone 116
bills this year and there are well over
a thousand bills in the legislature all
to get in the general court
so those that have made it through where
they're amended now are going back and
forth for committees of conference
and this is what we call the crazy time
when we're all trying to figure out
where we're going to go with these bills
and how we're going to do it
some people have we may have a bill in
there which we love like the career
technical education bill to improve
pathways for students to
obtain a certificate in a skill area
however they attach to it all this other
stuff all these amendments which are so
different than education
as i mentioned workforce housing
zoning and planning
issues
health and human service issues medicaid
issues how all those are attached to
that particular bill i just mentioned
so now we have about a week in which we
gotta resolve that if we can resolve it
and come out with something that both
sides agree upon then it goes to the
governor for his attention
so it's a long process we're getting
close to the end it's uh may 26th is our
last day
we have to have everything done
everything done
on may 26th
except for the interim study bills which
we can work on through june so
any questions from those attending today
this is kind of an informal work session
for us
i hope i've confused you huh
long drawn-out process it's not a simple
process but it is a good way to make
sure the public gets a opportunity to
get involved so back to where we are
here
we have these 15 bills right now which
we got to look at in terms of interim
study and they're all on the table where
their copies are on the table and we'll
take a look at them right now
we can either
have individual subcommittees dealing
with these or we can have committee of
the whole
there are several topics i've noticed
where there's a lot of people suggesting
they'd like to be a participant in it
and maybe just wise to just have a
committee the whole as that committee
and for everybody to be a participant in
it so
keep that in mind as we roll through
this uh dave do you have anything else
to add here at this time or or mel
i i think you've got it um you've got it
some swedish with covered today that and
um can watch us
go through some of the more complex
nuance
that uh
yeah it's um it's quite a process
so the the if i'm kind of looking at the
same sheet that i hope everybody else is
looking at
so the first one on top there's 11 37
this is relative to the duty of school
boards to provide education
uh i'll read what i have in the
committee report here this bill provides
more than the title provides more
research is needed for what is needed
for school board duties concerning
superintendents parents teachers etc in
the past few years issues have been
brought up
on
parental input student teaching etc this
interim study will allow us to research
existing laws rules policies and may
maybe suggest different laws and
regulations of how school boards conduct
themselves and what their duties are
it's open to discussion now from the
committee
i i see here that represent hall you had
indicated you may like to be on that
bill or not
i see representative tanner's name down
there too i don't see linda here
um
uh who who here had their hand or who
would like to be on that anybody here
referencing hobson
bobson
corneli
anybody else
what what should be the goal of this
particular group if you look at that
bill
it's it stirred a lot of comment
eleven thirty second comments on them
well from the committee here you know in
other words i'm trying to get a
direction for the people are going to be
working on that
sure i mean i think the um the bill as
as glenn introduced it enumerates uh a
series of additional responsibilities
that school boards would have
i think a lot of those responsibilities
are are
are
things that that superintendents
generally
generally have but but of course
everything that the superintendent does
the school board's responsible for
as well but the school board doesn't
actually have to
um be the
board that does all of those things so i
think that's that's an important
distinction here
with how current law
says these are things that the school
board has to do
not necessarily um
things that
that the superintendent can um
you know can do and uh and
and you know approve and uh
you know acting on behalf of the board
any other discussion do we need to have
a laundry list of duties in something
like this or can it be
local decision
those are questions i guess would be
asked by that group
so
there are four
rick that's one of the i think that's
one of the issues here yeah that is
how much do you legislate the list
vis-a-vis that of
what should be the prerogative of the
local school board
and i think that's going to be the task
of this group
is trying to identify what the
parameters should be from a legislative
standpoint
not necessarily getting into
every item
that would then preclude
locals from doing a certain thing that
they may want to do that would be
outside what that list might be that's
going to be the challenge i believe in
that group
you know i was when i've served on
school boards myself probably the the
big responsibility had was to develop an
annual budget
and that was it you know
primarily and of course we used to work
with the municipality as well
taxes
representative porter do you have
i was just i see you thinking over there
yeah i was just saying working on that
annual budget i mean that's a huge thing
that they have to do
and if you make up a list of all these
other things
i i feel pretty strongly about
maintaining as much local control as
possible with stuff like this
because sometimes the community doesn't
need what another one community doesn't
need what another community wants
um and i know when when we were in uh
when i was in municipal and county that
was one thing we
it didn't matter what party you belonged
to the idea was we don't make laws to
make one town happy that's going to make
every other town
have to do something that they've never
done before or don't need to do
so
you know just a word of caution who's
ever working on this that you don't want
to make the list
you don't want the hand of the thumb of
the state on local issues and schools
are local
so we have i have on the sheet here
four names which would
be on this if we have a subcommittee it
was uh president cordelli represent
hobson representative tanner and
represent hall of course represent
tanner's not here to object
no she yeah we had we had discussed this
okay um so if if um
we're good with that we'll go ahead with
that group working on that and you gotta
bring back some kind of recommendation
as to where we need to go with that
okay
that puts 1137 aside
next bill is 11 41.
relative to special education services
for children in charter public schools
it's kind of we had the mou bill
also there was a special education study
committee last fall that heard and
received much testimony this amended
bill addresses some of the issues raised
by parents
these include perceived intimidation and
individualized education plan iep
meetings by the presence of district
lawyers which can is contrary to federal
law concerning allowed
participants
there were also complaints about having
to sign non-disclosure agreements in
order to enter into mediation which also
is against federal law we also heard
testimony of incidents
where documents have been missing or
inaccurate in student files so an an
amendment to the bill includes
provisions for parental access to
records issues remain however in looking
at existing administrative rules that
exceed state and federal law and what
statutory changes still are needed the
majority agreed that interim study was
the best way to continue looking at
these issues
do we still feel the same way we had
some discussion with the
the way it works or having that mou set
at the beginning of the year
regarding kids which are in charter
schools to have an iep
as far as how's the sending district
or the resident district going to handle
that
that program for that youngster
represent you've been involved with that
quite a bit i have and uh i i my
question i guess would be to
representative cordelli because it was
his amendment to this bill
that really sort of
put language behind all of the concerns
and
so
you know my question to to you
representative cordelli would be
do you feel that the bulk of the issues
were addressed through
the legislation that went through
this year
um i i guess
the two
um
rick mentioned it in his uh
uh summary here um two main issues that
i was trying to get at
um that i i don't think did go through
legislation was
the
[Music]
participants in an iep meeting
and also
the non-disclosure agreements
um uh
i think those were the the
two of the main areas that i was trying
to get at with the amendment
um
and uh
i have to go back and look because i
think that one of those
areas the department did subsequently
put out a technical document technical
advisory
on one of those areas but i have to go
back and read what i think it may have
been on the lawyer at the ie the
participant in the iep meeting yeah
right
yeah i need to go back and
look at that
um
but
i think clearly from what we heard from
parents
over the past year or so
there were parents who
had concerns in those two or three areas
so rick yeah so thank you um so so i
guess back to i think the question that
you sort of put out there is um you know
would would would
some or all of the
aspects that 1141 was going after could
those be covered through the the mou
between a charter and a um yeah i think
that was senate bill 238
was it
mou bill i i don't i don't remember the
bill number on that
but but you know can the can a
combination of the mou
and um i mean now we also have the
office of the special education um
uh
advocate
you know provide the the additional
supports that 1141 was trying to do
well i i
that's where i am with the advocate
will that help can we take care of it
administratively rather than having to
do it legislatively
um
that would be my question uh to the
committee right now and and glenn you
you you're indicating that
what i um
i would not have a problem with waiting
and
seeing what the advocate
can do in this area and see
how many
problems or complaints that
they might get on these two areas um
before doing anything more because um
much of this is uh already in federal
statute
um so uh you know
we could possibly hold off
so so with that would it be fair to do
do an nr
uh pending um feedback from the um the
um
o sea
yeah i have no problem with that either
yeah
we we had a study on this earlier that
you were on representative mullin and
representative cordelia myself along
with senator reagan
and then we've also gone with the
discussion with the advocate the child
advocate um
so i i personally would like to
wait and see how that you know works
and then and also together can i just
ask one question of you uh mr chairman
do you know anything about the
performance audit that is supposed to be
performance audit has not been completed
in fact it's just on the front side
uh so
performance artists take a long time um
that's done by the lba
um yes forever cordelia
i believe that there was
uh possibly last week a meeting of the
um
uh performance audit oversight committee
um i wrote senator reagan to see if
there was any update from that meeting
on this topic but i have
not heard back from them i i think maybe
the senate was a little busy last week
also so uh
i will follow up with senator reagan to
see if we can get an update
i've talked with senator reagan and he
told me he hadn't heard a thing
back
so rick it would seem to me well to hold
on this period yeah i think that's where
we need to be on this i i don't think we
should put a subcommittee together or
even a committee a whole i think we
ought to just take action on this
uh in november you know up or down
and it looks seems to me that we want to
just hold off
and wait another year until this audit
would get done until we find out where
we are
get some good information in from the
school districts
okay so we won't do anything with that
one the chair
yes i'm looking at an email that i
received from
representative weber
and
evidently that legislative performance
audit oversight committee is meeting
today okay
a lot going on
this is it's very busy out there so
we'll skip over 11 41 and we won't have
a committee we won't have a committee
the whole either we'll just wait and
take it up in november or october in
october
everything here has to go before the the
whole general court though that's that's
the ultimate end of it here okay number
three here hb 1229
establishing a committee to study school
meal programs in new hampshire's public
schools and non-sectarian schools that
accept public funds
the education committee has been
approached this year with several bills
that request we study with foods
programs schools are using and what
programs are not working
we have been approached with bills that
want to explore how granite state
students can take advantage of our
natural resources and farms
that will benefit the students
nutritionally and our farmers
financially some questions revolve
around whether local resources can
alleviate supply chain issues
and whether we can rely on them
systematically for these reasons and
more we need to decide on a preliminary
structure of how to study these topics
yeah
go ahead represent mullet thank you um i
think you threatened me with uh leading
this subcommittee or this interim study
committee at one point mr chairman um
am i correct that this would be a study
com an interim study of whether or not
we're going to have a study
no i mean the bill was to establish a
study i i i got that but you know we had
some bills come forward like like the
one dealing with local produce
and can we sustain local produce
throughout the entire school year
would we have winters here and they
don't in florida so they can do such
things
so i think it ought to be regarding the
entire nutrition program we have in our
schools breakfast program lunch program
what are the issues
are there needs for future legislation
if so what are those
i think there's potential in in this
topic here it's we certainly had i don't
know how many bills we had come forward
on it but we must add at least three
yes you also get into a financial issue
because i would think those items that
fresh food and everything will cost a
little more
i hope they you know local but i would
think local programs could cost
more than what you'd like for
supermarket or
yeah this is something that we need to
watch commissioner jasper did come here
and testify in the committee
department of agriculture
foods and marketing our marketing and
foods
and that was one of his concerns so it's
legitimate that we should be looking at
so
i would you know suggest that if we have
a committee representative mullen
who would like to be on that committee
with representative mullen
represent hobson
anybody else
i'm representing nelson so i i will put
on that committee
ellison
woodcock also had his name down there
he's not here
yeah she's on there yeah you're you're
on there reps and hall you're on there
um are there any other representatives
that uh
like food
yeah she's out today so
she's not well
so
okay
lycus is down
so i'm going to put
representative mullen you can chair that
committee
you
you're welcome
and then hobson
um ellison
nelson
hall woodcock and liquous
anybody else want to work on that
you're all willing to get in you know
involved with it
remember the committee itself has to
come forward with some kind of
recommendation to the body of the hole
here so
it's a worthy topic
number four
requiring reports concerning school
policies and classroom recordings and in
classroom observers
it's a pretty hefty topic
this bill would require superintendents
to submit a report to the department of
education on school policies concerning
in classroom videos the committee
believes this bill needs more study to
look at existing policies and rules
whose bill was this
i see he's upstairs right now
yes is it showing videos or somebody
videoing the classroom mothering
he's coming in california in the next 10
days
um mr chair yes did we get a report from
the school boards association that there
were numerous
reports on this
well we've had legislation here before
representative cordelli sponsored that
years ago
and one year later we were back
revisiting it
um
we got into a lot of confidentiality
issues
special education issues
issues student teaching issues
on it went
and there is school board policy that as
a result of all that a boiler plate was
put forward
on how to address that
i thought we did a pretty thorough job
with that coming up with that as a
result of the stuff we ran into back
when glenn was you know dealing with us
two years in a row or maybe it was a
year in between i don't know
it was two years in a row we put it out
there
and we got trampled the next year until
we got that fixed by things that it
never came up during the public hearings
yeah yeah yeah
so is there need for us to address that
representative porter is the pub
the existing law does it deal with
um
students making videos with their phones
within the classroom
i mean that might be a change that's
occurred since that law was
written by
representative cordelli
i mean i don't know i don't know what
the statute is of cell phones in the
classroom is an issue in itself right
but
do does that does the statute now
require school districts to have
policies
concerning
the students use of their phone to
videotape
what occurs in the classroom it's an
interesting point i don't know i don't
believe so
i don't think i'd address that going on
memory mr chair yes this is also dealing
with in-person classroom observers as
well
brett moffatt's not here i don't know if
i'm supposed to be fighting for him well
no
yeah yeah he did mention that that you
know
parents were according to what it was
coming across from mike is that they
were not being allowed into the
classroom
represent
porter i was just wondering what whether
that might have something to do with
student confidentiality especially where
special education is concerned
i mean
there are times when you don't want
parents in the classroom i.e when you're
giving statewide examinations
we had a policy
also with our younger students when we
talked about kindergarten one
we didn't want parents coming in at the
beginning of the year
when the yes
the kindergarten teacher or the
preschool teacher was trying to get a
handle on things
mother saying this and teachers saying
that
was not a very good situation so there
are times where
i think that decision making has to be
up to the school
uh and and you can have pta pto ptc's
where you can work with and inform them
and i think through that process a
parent-teacher club or organization or
association
they will understand and i've never had
one object and they understood that
policy
so um what do you think dave
mr chair is this similar to representing
moffett's wanting to collect
material on gifted i mean if his intent
here
is merely to collect what the policies
would be
that's one thing because we don't know
what those policies are because
of all the many school districts we have
there are three a variety of different
options
so if this is merely a fact of
having the superintendent submit the
report and send the the local policies
once those are done then you can begin
to look at what those policies are
because i don't know
what the intent of the law or what the
proposal is here other than to collect
the respective policies it doesn't say
have a policy it says collect the
policies
correct
i think that could also be used as a
clearinghouse a one-stop shop for uh for
somebody who wants to
spy on kids
or something like that or take take
other action you know
i don't know if um
if the current statute
limits in person just to parents
could be any member of the public
and
and i think
you know we've got to
allow building principles
to um to obviously
be able to you know protect the safety
and security of the students in their
care
so what do you think
sis
it's a very difficult topic and you
can't compare one district to another
they're all different local school
boards run the show differently
and as an ex-principal
i always had parents check into the
office
first when they came in what's your
purpose what you're here for that's our
responsibility to know who's in the
building in case even if there's an
emergency a fire alarm goes off you
gotta know who's in your building
but there's a lot of other issues go
well beyond that so
um
at this point in time i
i think if somebody wants to pursue that
on their lonesome they can do that but
to
have a whole study committee on it i
think we're
yeah
so if if representative moffat wants to
pursue this
he's
got my blessing
so i you know personally i don't think
it's we got 15 bills here folks
which ones are really
top shelf and which ones are
maybe not on the shelf
yes
per me
he he's
standing in for representative balducero
whereas al's not here and he's vice
chair of that committee
well i think that
i i think
he's
if the if he's the only one that really
wants to pursue that
then he's welcome to do that we're not
saying no
um so
let him do that you know there may be
some of something he knows that we don't
know right here now um
that he can work with his own community
on representative porter it's important
to remember too that our only
recommendations coming out of these
interim study committees is
recommend future legislation or don't
recommend future legislation so we only
have those two options
that you know so a lot of these topics
this gives us a chance to delve a little
more deeply in them into them but it
does not put any kind of
responsibility on future
um
legislators to do something about it so
the only advantage to having a study
right now is like when we did in the
concussion bill years ago
after studying it and looking at it and
researching it and inviting people and
doing that we came up with some good
stuff yeah and
went forward and that can happen but it
doesn't come up end up with a bill and
sometimes the bill recommendation that
gets worked on
doesn't make it the next session anyway
yeah so
okay so we'll leave that up to
representative moffat to move forward if
he so desires and
we will have to discuss it anyways in
october
okay next one 1313
relative rights to freedom from
discrimination in higher education
the discrimination law passed last year
in hb2
applied to k-12 but then did not
specifically identify post-secondary
education
the bid bill did state that nothing in
that subsection of law shall be
construed to limit the academic freedom
of faculty members of the university
system in new hampshire or the community
college system of new hampshire
to conduct research publish lecture or
teach in the academic setting however
concern has
been brought to the attention of
committee members that there may be need
for language with the law to address
address
to also address curriculum and
instruction at the post-secondary levels
the committee prefers the option of
working closely with higher education
administration to obtain assurances that
policy in place ensuring that all
students know and experience the
community college system college and
university systems as welcoming and
inclusive place places to live work and
study the education committee recommends
interim study and is hopeful that by
working together we can build bridges
and models of inclusivity
uh without the need for further
legislation action by the general court
i think that just came out a blurb out
of the committee report
that's all these are so that's um
i can remember i was i believe the
sponsor that bill my feeling is right
now
that
i'd like to work with
the two systems
and
i don't know right now if it's even
worth this committee study
further discussion thoughts
no i agree
okay
so we're not going forward with that one
no
the next one is one though i think that
we need to focus a little bit on here
um hb 1366
cooperative school reapportionment
uh this bill was submitted for the
purpose of making it easier to submit
petitioned articles locally with regard
to proposed cooperative school district
apportionment modifications
the rsa 195 colon 22 presently requires
such a proposal to show signatures of at
least 10 percent of cooperatives
districts qualified voters
this requirement is daunting
particularly in larger districts however
during the committee work
work it was all understood that
different different dynamics occur in
sb2 communities that need further consul
consideration before moving forward with
this legislation
reapportionment
uh representative porter so a couple of
things here number one there are a
number of bills that have to do with
cooperative school districts that we
might clump together
and number two um
it was just noted that in the town of
croydon they needed to get half of their
registered voters to a meeting
and they got more than
half their registered voters to a
meeting um that's a pretty high standard
and certainly it was done when people
are um driven
by something important to do it so
i don't think 10 is unreasonable um
that's pretty low bar cons considering
what croydon just did
on that point rick you've got the
yep and 1679.
why don't we just put those three those
three together i think that's what we
need to do and
my recommendation would be that there
there's a number issues not just
reapportionment but election of of the
board members themselves
as we found out with the when we did
look at this cooperative school board
issue
and how to elect folks we found that
some cooperatives
they're all 30 what two or three of them
are totally different from each other
some were formed in the 1960s
some have not really looked
in depth at how they're put
how things have changed within their
communities since those agreements
articulation agreements went into effect
and of course populations have changed
wealth of the community has changed on
it goes
uh so
i i think i'd like to see us combine the
three of them together and have a
committee of the whole
yeah
just uh to look at that
the
the there was one issue that we had
looked at in potential
uh amending language was that
every 10 years we do a census here in
the state
um
is it worth our considering that every
10 years
you've got to look at these articulation
agreements and see if you're apportioned
properly in terms of representation from
the communities
that was one of the questions which came
up and i think it needs resolution
representative porter um that would also
require funding i would imagine
because you couldn't it wouldn't be
something that
you would do
without an expert helping you
like
redistricting for the whole state we
don't do without being advised
by people who know how to do it
so
um it seems to me that it would be
something that would need to be budgeted
for so there would be some money
available for communities to do that
there again that be something that the
committee would look at and you know
want to discuss
so i i don't want to comment on that
right now but
any other representative cornell i i
don't understand that well being from
manchester because we don't have
anything like this but don't these
cooperative districts go in with a
memorandum of understanding when they
join and get together and
should it be us telling them what to do
with their
we we looked at that they have
articulation agreements when they first
form
and those agreements then have to go on
and be approved by the state board of
education
uh we found that
a number of districts
have different numbers on their boards
right now some have even numbers where
the initially it never spoke to whether
you should have an odd number and of
course that's a challenge when you're
having a vote
and we know the maximum number is 15 and
this the smallest number is three
members
but those articulation agreements like
the district that i'm in right now
i'm in a cooperative
the haverhill cooperative school
district is a cooperative district of
one town
i initially had two towns or two high
schools woodsville had a high school and
haverhill corner or haverhill had a high
school or academy
the the academy folded and and now they
have seven
at-large
uh board members elected in the town of
haverhill and they're all representing
the town of haverhill
um there's time for an overhaul of that
agreement
um
and and that same thing is occurring in
some other districts not as much as that
but where we have a
districts that have
populations that have so shifted
that it's it's it's out of whack it's
really out of whack and the
person coming out of that very small
district now really
you know other than being elected at
large
possibly
representation is not one man one vote
type representation
it's a huge issue
so rick
rick why don't um
as as i think representatives porter and
milor have suggested that and and you've
spoken to why don't we have one
committee of the whole study
interim study on on basically relative
to cooperative schools
governance re i'm sorry governance
withdrawal and dissolution
because that's the um withdrawal is the
subject of
1399 and dissolution is the subject of
1679. yes and so
and and uh board reapportionment is
really governance
everybody agree with that to take those
three bills and lump them into one study
so we'll do that as a committee of the
whole yeah great thank you
okay let's move on
uh where are we here
1373 relative to the best interest of
the child of the student for a change of
school or assignment that's manifest
education hardship
we have done this over and over and over
again glenn
where do you want to go on your bill
uh this is this is
based on the new information we have
gotten um
during within the hearing process
um
i don't think that it requires at this
point a study committee um you know if
a member wants to look at it and get
involved they can always bring back
legislation but i don't think it
requires a study committee at this point
everybody concur in that
let's let's let's move on
1399 we took care of that
with the cooperative school
um 14.99
14.99 is relative a charter school
public school eligibility for state
school building aid
this is a topic that's going to keep
popping up at us not just this but
school building aid as a whole
um
you're all familiar with the tail
the amount of debt we have which is over
30 million dollars or
we have to it was remember
570 580 million dollars years ago and
we're going to pay off that debt by year
we're getting there
each year we appropriate 50 million
dollars for school building aid of which
out of that comes paying off the debt
which we call the tail
and that's over 30 million dollars so
that maybe leaves what 18 million
thereabouts for
for
renovation and new facilities
um it just doesn't make it and we know
that
if you talk to amy clark over there at
the doe right now it's over what in
total
monies needed for building that she has
her death 700 and something thousand
dollars of which you cut that down maybe
40 percent of it 45 of that and that's
what we'd have to appropriate
um
that's just for school houses then the
career tech ed centers are coming up
and
that schedule has is getting at the end
of that rotation and we're going to
start going forward again
and that's not a cheap thing capital
improvement project so we got that and
now we have this business with charter
schools
and the issue with charter schools is
how many charter schools own the
buildings
or are they leased facilities and do we
put state money into a leased property
do we study this
i i think we should
uh it's going to come up again
uh i'd like to know
are there any charter schools that
actually own their buildings now
i think they're like two or four yeah i
think so okay my concern is this is that
the state has already committed that
they're not going to commit any more
money
and so you are you know you have
a finite amount of money
that's already you've got people in the
queue that they can't fund
so it seems you know if you want to
study fine but it just seems to me that
until the state
provides an adequate amount of money for
school funding why are you going to add
another category into this into this uh
chiseling this up with this piece of pie
here this piece of pie there i
mean
there's no commitment on the state
to add more money to this and we've been
fighting this thing for 10 years
and regardless of what the
administration is
there doesn't seem to be a wherewithal
for the
state to really want to put any more
money into this thing so why would we
add another category into this potential
just a question i have in my mind
would you see a
process
part of this study because we've heard
from
representative hill who's the chair of
the school building authority
um about problems with the whole process
um and the need to you know look at the
process
that they go through now in that uh
the authority
uh as i recall has to come up with
plans and recommendations not even
knowing whether the community
you know has voted to go ahead with any
kind of building project
so in
some ways it's the part before the horse
for the authority
this whole process the when you talk
about the school building authority
that's a group that's made up of about
five people
a fire marshal's one then you have
people from dra in in department of
education commissioner
and it's the application for building
aid comes into doe they look at it they
try to prioritize these
they make sure they're complete
and then they send it on to the school
building authority
school building authority was initially
put together to look at the bonding
authority of the state and the
capability of the state being able to go
that direction
and then once it goes by the school
building authority of course when it got
to school building authority the last
year there was question
do we look at the same criteria for
evaluating these applications
as the doe did and initially putting
that recommended list together
they wanted to use a different criteria
that was more fiscal oriented
we as policy said no no no the process
is that they come in and they they
they're rated based upon x number of
points 250 275 points something like
that based on safety uh demographics
uh small room facilities special
education all that are in there
we
determined that it should be the same
criteria until we
the legislature makes adjustments to
this whole process from the school
building authority it goes then to the
state board of education
where they have to make a determination
of which ones they're approving
um and then that's all be done by
january 15th of each year
so
uh the process itself needs
a look
and
maybe some re
i've i've heard from amy over the d.o.e
there's times that they don't even see a
need for the school building authority
um
so rick um on 1499 i i think this
committee would have a hard time either
recommending or not recommending for
future legislation this topic without at
least
some study work on it
um
and uh and i think what you've put out
and what others have put out certainly
raised a lot of questions and in order
for us to be able to
to at least put a i think a a
hopefully a helpful you know final
report together in october
uh to be printed in the calendar we
should we should at least identify those
things
okay go ahead are you looking for
this is a huge topic and i
if we think we're going to sit down and
resolve it in two or three you know
tries during the summer time yeah i mean
i mean i don't think we're going to
resolve it no but i think i think what
we can do is is put together a report
that that either says something like
recommended
for future legislation pending further
investigation into um into
make up what the what the things are
dissolution of a of a charter use of um
obligations of uh you know
you know to um
to
the state or the or other credit holders
uh
or not recommended for future
legislation because
and lists two or three uh things but i
think that's going to require a meeting
to do not to come up with the answers
but at least
at least frame up the argument
i would agree with that i i'd really
like to understand the process better i
don't have a good hold on the process
of building aid charter schools
are you talking about building aid or
just charter schools all of it together
yeah charter schools exempt from
building it yeah
there they are
when we put this together
several years back
we we mimicked what they were doing over
the state of maine
and we got the
the whole
plan what they're doing from duke
albany's who was the commissioner of
education over there
he used to be my athletic director
and and um they had gone through
years of putting this together and
if their their whole process is a little
bit more complex than ours because they
deal with leasing as well
um i would suggest that if we're going
to be looking at that topic we need to
put together a commission study of some
kind in future years work with the
architects work with
engineers work with the department
work with educators that are familiar
with this process maybe elsewhere and
come up
you know we're talking about just like
the adequacy formula it's a similar
formula and it's very complex
i don't think we're going to do it
during interim study and charter schools
that's just just the tip of the iceberg
right right and the the you know the
outcome from an interim study could be
recommended for future legislation
through um through uh commission work to
investigate
the uh you know complexity through a
commissioned study like up through an
interim study we could identify
just what we've been talking about right
now and get that down so
legislation could be put forward with
those type of recommended based on some
of those recommendations heavy points to
be examined
by a study community an interim study
could take care of that within several
meetings working with amy
clark and others there's even one or two
i don't think it's a huge list yeah i'm
saying yeah a couple a couple times
so
so so maybe porter and luna luna will be
on it well i'd like to be on it too
okay
so we have porter luna lad and hobson
anybody else would like to be on that
this is for
building aid charter building aid the
whole nine yards okay we'll leave at
that
and where i'm working pretty closely
with i'll i'll chair that one and then
it'd be lad luno
hobson porter okay
yes
district save money by doing helping
this charter school fix something would
it be could it be cost-effective for
them to help them
save money because you're going to send
all the kids somewhere if they don't and
they cost them more to take the kids
back
okay number 10.
requiring high school students to
complete a half year required course in
the introduction to philosophy
what do you think about that
yeah uh
in the uh adequate um
education bill we that we passed um
remind me i i think we put logic in
there do we have ethics in there too
is that also part of that with logic and
rhetoric rhetoric
though scary word rhetoric yeah
for a theory of knowledge
so we're getting there going back to
your initial thing you talked about a
half credit in this subject area
yeah but it was specifically i was
trying to get towards um
philosophy as a means of inquiry and
that's um
using the theory of knowledge and
philosophy of science
but also added in logic and ethics
because a lot of times these lines are
blurred people
blur ethics up with
science one is a
statement of facts factual science as
opposed to a moral statement which is
not a is a statement it's an ought
statement
and i think um a lot of uh par what
society screws up in in their arguments
is that they're mixing it up
and that's why anywhere with an interim
study i'm not sure
reps in
hall yeah i don't think this is right i
i think developing curriculum is local
um i don't see that we would have
you know if you want a philosophy or on
that
mandatory list that would be one thing
but this is about how to integrate
a topic into a curriculum thinking
skills or whatever i i don't think this
is even our role
uh
well perhaps announced
are there enough people to teach this
well i would think that um a lot of its
literature could be taught by
english
teachers also what is history and also
some of the science
as in the philosophy of science
but as the point of um whether we should
mandate it or not uh
philosophy the love of wisdom is a
foundational to all learning
um
i think the learning the foundation of
putting together our thoughts
uh
is where you have to start with and i
think that uh they kicked socrates to
the corner really quickly
in most schools
further discussion
so rick um i i don't think we need uh a
study on um
on 1630
you know i think a lot of these types of
subjects are also college level i'm not
an expert in this area and i would defer
to the educators like yourself rick and
and others on
to this but uh but you know i you know i
think what you're talking about here
you know some pretty heavy-duty things
that might require a more fully
developed frontal lobe and and things
like that to really be able to
to process and and and
you know and and develop that you know
area of inquiry
uh certainly um um you know k-12 schools
do use um uh do you know
provide students with curriculum
um that that covers a lot of critical
thinking skills it may not quite be to
the level that uh that you're suggesting
here but students might not be ready for
that
uh i think you're selling our high
school kids a little bit short there but
so be it yeah i'm i'm i you know i'm i'm
not selling them short i've certainly
had um two high school kids of my own
and
and spent a long time on on school
boards and a lot of time volunteering
in schools
and uh while i think some high school
kids
are are certainly
great thinkers and
probably more mature than i was when i
was in in high school i know that a lot
uh aren't and continue to develop that
maturity into their into their 20s
and uh and that's no fault of their own
that's just physiology i think so
representative porter and then represent
all uh so so i'm gonna step out on a
limb a little bit here
um
i'm concerned given
house bill 2
and recent statements that have been
made
about
activist teachers
for example that
making this a requirement in high school
might be very difficult
to do
without getting into trouble
depending on what
um
issues were used to help the students
learn these skills and
i think we need to step back from that
right now and let things settle down
until we know
the ramifications of
what's occurring in our schools right
now
and just to caution
don't make them have to do something
that if they try to do and do it wrong
in some people's views it's going to get
them into trouble
represent ford
this might be one of those subjects
that we might want to suggest or in some
way encourage
in a response such as a gifted and
talented program
and so you might put reason for example
logic those kinds of things just in how
you make a statement that isn't valid
which really does skirt the kinds of
problems that you're talking about if
you're going to make a statement about
something then your logic has to be
reasonable
in other words it's not convincing
that that kind of thing might be brought
into being a teacher or someone like
that it's just an
aspect of writing clearly
and therefore not as subject to the
title false lawsuit
and similarly you might do it in
mathematics
and others in a different way of the
application of mathematics
which you do a certain kind of
structured reasoning
without getting it all into the subject
that you're talking about any subject
that you might do it that way and
certainly if it's part of a gifted and
political
level
rick
you know i think um
currently in schools
i believe the socratic method is used
every day
i mean there's a there's a theory called
uh inquiry
inquiry teaching which does exactly what
uh representative saudi is talking about
where you ask questions you you
basically
help students
develop their thinking process by the
questions i mean
there's nothing more powerful than a
powerful question
rather than a statement as you're
working with kids i think that's
happening in classrooms all over the
state right
you know i i can
just tell you through my own experience
not in the state but we did have that
program in the schools and what came in
as a result we had a
an individual on our staff which her job
was
gifted teacher that's you know she was a
gifted person but she would she taught
kids which are identified as gifted and
there's a whole criteria we had to go
through to identify
giftedness
um
and we used achievement scores she had
295's or higher you had an
uh
iq score of 130
going up maybe a maybe down 128 but that
was it
uh leadership uh recommendations
creativity uh recommendation of parent
recognition of teacher
and what we found out is that we use the
junior great books process i mentioned
that a little bit when we talked about
this earlier this year
and a number of other ways of thinking
as you re you say representative meyer
the the ability for inquiry thinking
and
what we found is that the program we had
soon became a program for the whole
school
and and it was
shared with all the teaching staff
and
the level of questions and answers was
so much different than the factual
and and and you can see there's a lot
more thought involved with it and that's
i think that's as i look at this
this topic of philosophy i look more at
this methodology of how to get thinking
going on and it should be
utilized by everybody in the school
and
to ensure that we're getting kids to
get to that
reasoning level and logic and thinking
that is
gonna
you know really give them
the the tools to be ready
uh for life uh so
to integrate this as a separate course
i think we're starting to look like
maybe a post-secondary course
to integrate it in and embed it as a
methodology for teaching and instruction
through all this correct we should be
doing that right right from the lower
intermediate grades
and maybe more than that all the way
through
so we're talking about teacher
methodology or instruction
which is a local responsibility but
um
i have not seen anything come out of doe
in terms of this in terms of giftedness
and we are a state that does not support
that financially whereas a lot of states
do they used to do it through their
special ed program in fact some states
had identified as a
not a handicapping condition and maybe
it was for some kids a lot of kids are
in trouble our gifted kids they're just
bored out of their minds
and look to other ways of you know
showing their
the responses so
i'd like to see it in start but i don't
know it's a separate course i i i don't
know how to do that uh it's going to be
a very costly deal too
but we shouldn't worry about the costs
here in policy
so what's the
any over here any feelings on
representatives yes
thank you
okay sure yes
you know and and and you might work with
representative moffatt on gifted
education
dr ranzuli down uconn would you know
support what you're doing
okay
perhaps
i have to say this
when i had my preschool kindergarten
all those kids were gifted
kids are all gifted parents all know
their kids are gifted there's just
different ways of being gifted
um
my favorite was a little boy oh just a
sweetheart who's
was struggling all the way through in
reading in math and second grade but one
day a bird
crashed into my picture window and died
and i didn't know what kind of bird it
was and i knew that this kid was hunting
with his grandfather a lot so i stuck it
in the freezer and i brought it into
school the next time i came in and i
said what kind of bird is this and he
gave me
all this information about the kind of
bird where it lived what it ate how many
eggs it laid the colors of the eggs this
kid knew all that stuff but he couldn't
read and he couldn't write
so he was definitely gifted
but he probably wouldn't be in a gifted
program so
thank you
okay so represent saudi if you want to
pursue that go for it
okay next one down 1676
relative to making incentive grants for
school districts
16 what 64. oh i jumped one okay
requiring certain non-public school or
education service providers that accept
public funds to perform background
checks on all employees and volunteers
do we do that now
i think where the sticking point was on
this is the um
the um
efa program uses the term education
service providers in a very very broad
definition that includes um suppliers
and parents equipment suppliers too yeah
um
and
and and that obviously some of those
things like the amazon driver probably
doesn't need to pass a a security check
at least
for for this they may be passing an
amazon
security check but not one that's
imposed through this
type of um of statute so um so this
probably does require
some work if it's going to move forward
we had a bill another bill that was
working to try to find out if that was
even doable wasn't it
representative mcguire's bill that came
through
yeah to see if we could
do something
for all of the people
background checks for everybody through
one main
yeah but that was about having the state
be the clearinghouse for background
checks right i think this is a little
different that it's um that it's
it's requiring who should be um
receiving background or submitting to
background checks
and uh and who should be paying for them
it may get into that too i i
i don't recall but i think that's a i
think there's there's strong rationale
for for this and making sure that um
that
anybody that's um
that's that's in an educational setting
um receiving state funds
that that should be
you know submit to a background check is
is actually you know that there's one
being conducted
is the department of education currently
doing this no well we have attorney
fenton here perhaps she could update us
on what's going on
oh there she's hiding
oh
i didn't see you back there
how you doing i'm good how are you fine
thanks
so in regard to department of education
and criminal checks background checks
and all that
uh is there a group over there studying
this stock right now or is there
activity looking at that at the
department sure thank you for the
question my name is diana fenton uh with
the department of education for the
record um
yeah so this is an area that the
department is actively
working on constantly thinking about and
working on
historically
any kind of criminal background check
pursuant to rsa 189 colon 13 a was a
matter of employment only
i want to be clear that the department
did not play any role in background
checking in any capacity so that means
as a practical matter
prior to last year's legislative session
when the department issued a credential
to teach there was no background check
done as part of that it was a matter of
employment only the department
felt very strongly that it did not want
to license someone who might have
who might be unemployable pursuant to
the statute right that was a bad public
policy so uh pursuant to legislation
that was passed during the pandemic
the department is now doing background
checks on first-time
uh
educators
and uh teacher prep program candidates
that is done to help the colleges and
universities
um and the department is also doing
really a clearance a criminal history
clearance for for school bus drivers
which allows them to go statewide those
are two very different functions they
sound very similar but those are two
different functions representative
mcguire's
study commission i'm anticipating that
was your question
oh rats uh
her uh her study commission is a little
more narrowly tailored to take the idea
of what we've done with bus drivers
giving them that kind of statewide
mobility if you will to see what other
professions go
between districts
to alleviate the idea of having a
multitude of background checks
um from one district to another
porter
thank you so my question is
if someone is hired by prenda to be a
guide
and that guide is working with a group
of children
does that guide have to have a
background check
prior to
working with that group of children
the short answer is is yes i do know
that there was a lot of work that went
into that that system any of those
initiatives that the department rolls
out whether it's efas or prenda any of
those programs that is a natural
component of it as it was the learn
everywhere program what that background
check consists of i i i honestly i'm not
sure can i
if i called um
jones
piano teaching um
jones piano teaching okay because part
of my child's program is learning music
does joan have to have a background
check to work with my child
as part of the
efa program
um my i can't answer that exact
hypothetical i know that in any of the
programs the department has has rolled
out
the background check is a component a
component of it how it plays out in each
individual scenario
is a case by case so if joan
registers as an education service
provider with the department
my understanding is yes the there would
be a background check component to that
who would do the background check
uh
i don't know
okay
that's been my concern with this that
there
are people that should not be working
with children for obvious reasons and if
there's no requirement
that we check into them
this might be a wonderful place for them
to get access to children
nefarious way
there is a requirement i can't tell you
off the top of my head what what that
requirement is
you're welcome
so let me get this right if
you're going to go to pete's piano
teaching
and you as a parent decide i'm going to
send my child over here
and
then the parents also collecting a efa
to get reimbursed for that
is that you know does the parent just
have to show the invoice
the cost to
kate baker
or or does before you're going to get
that invoice paid that that pete's is
going to have to have that kind of check
that you just spoke of
i would have to look into the details of
the efa program i know from kate baker's
testimony they have a process by which
they vet
the people that they work with but i
don't know that process off the top of
my head
i think what the the question is
what role does the department actively
play in conducting the background check
recognizing that the department is a
governmental entity
thereby
can get the federal background check
right now
the department
has a limited role to those groups that
i told you about which was the school
bus drivers the teacher prep program
candidates
and first-time educator applicants
it is a very limited role
my caveat
is always to recognize that the
department is actively building this
infrastructure
and
we have to be mindful of what the
department takes on not that there isn't
um
ability for the department to do so but
we just have to be mindful of creating
that infrastructure
the concern being that if
any balls are dropped it would directly
harm child safety so that's always my
representative
so then there was also the question
about
um the state police and the fbi and all
that
and my understanding from that was that
the fbi would
allows the department to do this
the fbi
might not allow
prenda to do it
um because they're not a whatever
do you is that accurate
so my understanding is similar to yours
that
there's two pieces that make up a
criminal background check there is the
federal fbi background check and there
is the state portion
anyone can have access to the state
portion if you want to
run my new hampshire criminal record you
can do so
um it is the federal background check
that is more limited and because that
because that is governed by the fbi
regulations my understanding is in
talking to the department of safety is
it you have to be a governmental entity
i.e a school district
a state agency in order to get that
background check
um i do know
however that there are certain um
exceptions to that rule right every rule
has some exceptions and so i know that
there were some like the adam walsh act
would on occasion allow for example like
a camp
right camps can have access to the fbi
background check i don't know the exact
loophole or avenue by which they get
access it but i know that there are some
non-governmental entities that get it
that's where my knowledge on that would
end and i would defer to the department
of safety but i can tell you and and i
will feel comfortable speaking for linda
tana tanner on this anytime you look
into this topic
it's just naturally complex and so yes
there are a lot of questions um
and and right now the department plays
that that limited role but it is a role
that we are taking on currently
right
yes rep representative it would seem to
me based upon this it would seem to me
that we should at least have a group
look at this it may only take one
meeting
or we have a report from kate and uh
who's ever responsible for the
department we now have
we now know who the learn everywhere
vendors are right now we now know who
the efa people are receiving it so it
seemed to me that it'd be an ideal time
over the summer to look at this
and uh then again i don't i don't see it
taking a whole lot of time but just to
get the clarification
as attorney fenton has said so we're
clear and
from that maybe some legislation that
may be needed to be more specific
than what's in this particular piece of
legislation that's before us right now
president cordelia um couldn't that also
be done by the
efa oversight committee i think that
they
have a meeting
in september
the only problem with that is that part
of this bill also applies to non-public
schools
so
i don't know that the efa oversight
committee they would be able to do the
efa part
but
i think we would be looking at
additional facilities if we're
going strictly on the language of the
bill
right for for example if the district
were to contract with a non-public
school
how many people would like to be on a
working committee on this
here right now
i had uh
porter mullen paul tanner
are there any others would like to be on
a committee like this
anybody else
hear me
put me down i think
one republican on the committee cordelie
i'll join you on that
it does raise a lot of interesting
questions
anybody else
okay so we have then
cordura cordelie lad porter mullen hall
tanner and cornell
on the committee
and i'm gonna have glenn uh chair it
okay so we will have that and
look forward to that okay number 12
let's see where we are here relative
making incentive grants for school
districts that improve in certain
assessment scores representative moffat
that was i think your bill wasn't it
yes it was mr unfortunate
i won't say anything yes it was mine i
was a prime okay
is it
uh we we put down interim study
um correct
we have you know a whole group doing
this because you weren't here at the
very beginning or should this be a small
group or do we need a group
well
thanks for asking mr chair if that was
directed to me uh
representative hobson and i met uh
informally with
some folks at d.o.a the commissioner and
uh mackenzie and caitlin and
a guy uh attorney fenn is a guy who
works here i can't remember his name
anyway uh yeah so so we chatted with
the folks at doa and they're very
interested in the concept there's a lot
of interest in other places as well
um
and
not not to get into the uh
the policy pieces here because if we do
have a
committee
but um
when we had the hearing in subsequent
exec session that we flagged some
questions and concerns things that we
needed to talk about if this if
something like this is to move forward
which we could get into in a interim
study committee
um
so anyway uh yeah obviously i'd be happy
to be involved with the committee to
look at the pieces of this that need
discussion
if uh
something like this was to move forward
at some point
represent porter
thank you mr chair and this is just an
interesting side note
um
recently um u.s world put out their
rankings of new hampshire high schools
and they didn't use standardized test
scores
and i just wanted to let everybody know
that hillsborough tearing came in quite
well in that in that listing and
ahead of places like pinkerton and even
concord
and some of the other school districts
that are
highly regarded in our state so
um
just to throw that out as a
little
cautionary tale go hellcats
represent hobson
and just a quick question back to rep
porter what did they use if they didn't
use
standardized test scores they used all
sorts of other factors like
getting preparation of a college high
school graduation rate etc etc there
were a lot of
parameters i didn't read the whole
statement of all the things that they
use but that not only were their schools
ranked in the state um but they were
ranked
nationally as well
um by the national rank you can look it
up you it you just look up us news and
world report new hampshire high school
and they'll get it to you
so
this is uh obviously a money bill too
when we're talking about putting forward
like a million bucks
to use as the carrot or the incentive
based upon a standardized test score
so obviously it's uh
would have a fiscal note too but a
question i have is that how do you
improve your test scores in your
building if your average score already
is at the 90th percentile
sure this came up when we had the
hearing and we had the exact session
um
schools would be uh
competing against themselves not against
anybody else and yeah of course if if a
school is very very school is very low
there's a great you know room for
improvement and
uh yeah we talked about that before
so in tackling that issue and coming up
with the formula um that that's what a
commit our committee if we have one
would would talk about
um when we met with d.o.a caitlin davis
had some specific recommendations as to
assessments uh that were very
interesting they were actually pretty
excited about the concept the actual
details obviously were not there yet
but that's one of the questions that
came up in committee that that is a good
question that we would talk about again
so who'd like to be on uh a study like
this
i i have
that was submitted to me by
representative miller paul ellison and
luno
okay and then hobson and
moffat i'm sure
amen you're in
anybody else on this one
okay so
we'll have seeing that you are the
sponsor of the bill i'm going to put you
in charge of the setting up the times
and all that so be a committee of the
of the five people there
uh 1676
all righty um yeah i'd like to see you
know there in the
uh way we
look at
how we deliver an adequate education
there's a number of indicators
of that besides just standardized tests
uh
representative porter mentioned a couple
of them on there but that's a laundry
list of a good 12 or 13 items
anywhere from career technical education
skills and pathways certification to
taking the asvab
to
attendance to suspension expulsion rates
all that stuff is part of it
and so you might be looking at that as
well as a way to assess
you know
or to at least consider
so with that
names again were
okay it would be
moffat
hobson luno ellison hall
thank you you're welcome
next one uh
1679 relative we did that
we put all the cooperative for those you
weren't here mike uh all the cooperative
bills are in one study of the whole
so we're going to do those all together
number 14
excuse me yes representative hall who is
on that committee with a cooperative
school who do you have that's that's
everybody oh that's everybody that's
that's the committee of the whole
um
hb 1680
this is another one where i think it's
important and i like to see this be a
committee of the whole as well
um
we we talked about a little bit of
finance to this year how we fund
adequate education
when it came to that last bill dealing
with the extraordinary
grant needs grant bill
dealing with equalized property
valuation for those eligible students
based on free and reduced meals
we also put a component in there dealing
with uh weighted
special ed
uh that's been taken out of that bill
but i'd love to see that you know that
it's it's all part of 1680.
and so i think there's some components
when 1680 that really deserve our
attention and attention of the whole
committee here
any
further discussion that's and we we've
already had several working groups on
that already this year but we will
continue that
and a lot of good information is coming
out of there
and i'm not necessarily agreeing with
everything but it's it's good stuff no
no but
but i think what we what we can agree on
probably is an approach um that uh that
looks at the uh definition and cost of
adequacy
and um and the approach to a fiscal
policy that um that sort of aligns with
with what we've uh with what the courts
have uh have indicated to us
yeah we also may want to keep our eyes
on conval right
what's going on there
uh so jumping to uh the last one we have
is hb234
i don't even remember that bill
relative to freedom of speech and
association on college campuses gen when
did we do that bill yes we did
no we did we were a subcommittee on that
bill mr chair and representative mullen
and i were on it
and we put it into interim study who who
chaired it was was it you that you had
it
i did share it commit it was retained
and we had
and then we had a five to zero vote
recommending itl
as i recall no this this was
no no i take that back
we recommended ies
fire study yes five to nothing vote
right right right and it was
yes
but i but i don't think it needs another
committee to study it personally
yeah we we had that done years ago too
when we looked at in the
the uh the
status was was put out by fire
and and uh
and since then we've seen some
improvements on our college campuses
yeah one of the things that we talked
about um at length in that subcommittee
was the fire report
in fact there were representatives there
who talked about
the uh
what they considered to be a a pretty
significant improvement because
we had unh that was doing okay keane was
in the red plymouth was yellow
by the time they got done with
all of their investigation and work
everybody was green so
that's where we want to be
if i remember correctly we interim
studied it because we wanted the uh
the young man who was the prime sponsor
to not get discouraged and moving on to
other legislation in the future so
i think a disruption of alexander maybe
yeah
two terms ago we had a similar bill the
not the last term when i was not here
but the term before that when i was here
and we uh jim grenier and i and and uh
maybe
uh representative cornell might have
been on we had a
we we had a
the the guy from unh came in
and i think
eventually out of that i think we get
their attention and some changes were
made even though nothing moved forward
so i think there was value just to
having that
committee before and and also shining a
light like we did
so we're we need to wrap this up here
today um
we cannot start any of these interim
study studies
in this facility until all the
committees of conference are done
and that will be on the 19th i believe
i hope and then the following week is
our last week in which we are in session
so we're looking at june basically
um
two uh memorial day is going to be
coming up and and then in june
uh they could be scheduled
and we can start um does anybody here
really have
travel plans or something coming up in
parts of june that we should be aware of
when are you having your sue uh i'm
leaving for the uk on the 19th of june
and i'm gone until the 30th
okay wow can you need somebody to carry
the bags or something
honestly the reason i'm going is because
this whole thing started two years ago i
was supposed to be at a wedding
that got cancelled and or you know
postponed and then postponed and then
canceled and uh
so
this is the
they have they have a child now this
couple
and
and yet and yet my right and yet my uh
travel voucher was going to expire so
off i go
well have fun anybody else who won't be
here
so we know dates here
4 to
21 june 4 to 21 june i will be at
several european venues
it is what it is
you get all that free travel in the
military
negative on that
okay
any others
can i just ask a procedural question
chairman led um
does lindsay schedule these meetings is
um no the the first name person has to
do this no i i know i'm i will be
responsible usually in the summer months
it's heather oh
got it
oh that will be lindsey this year
no that's right judy was not full-time
all right so i can get a hold of her and
then she would be the person okay great
thank you yeah
so again my apologies for that chunk of
time i'll be gone and um
so if not early june or later june um if
we could do it in the fall
hopefully in june but uh we'll work it
out all these have to notice has to go
in the calendar just like any other
committee meeting we have so the public
is aware
anything else
i think we're done thank you very much
we have an interesting speaker here on
thursday
yeah
i'm curious to know what the people in
poland think
yeah yeah that's good so so rick on your
on on the um
the motions that you're going to make on
thursday
is that
the
per the report that you sent out to the
committee yeah yeah
yeah so the four bills that are cfc
requested
um
are the four that you indicated in that
yeah yeah
per me are the four that you would yeah
the
senate can say no to seeds
you